hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within we
got a boss waiting for us at least
that's my assumption considering hey
they gave us me a lot of bullets us me
by the way I'm including you in this
with me it's like we're going on an
adventure together
- it's quite obviously going to be a
boss battle I don't need any more
judgments don't judge me I know what I'm
doing
maybe also there's an arena over there
did I mention that arena arena boss
battle yeah so should I just start
cranking on this yank right away or
should I wait until you tell me I need
to do it oh wait oh wait on the big
green glowing cranky Yankee yeah poop
poop it's dead okay so I need to reroute
this to be able to get all of this
together I need one more there's got to
be another one around here before I can
do this - Orpheus I should be retired by
now what's my name again I don't know
grab-grab I'm with this - detective I
wasn't even sports beard yeah hey look
another fields well that was awfully
convenient sure glad that happened
wait a minute okay I thought that was
the thing that I could have used there
hey what's over here
nothing oh boy okay so I need to find
out which one goes to which wound
so there's I'm assuming the white
glowing ones are the power so I need to
be able to send power to both lift the
supply and the auxilary it seems like I
wouldn't even need to use the
bottom-left one because it seems like
the one in the middle could supply both
the lift in the supply so I should do
that
oh no I'm wrong because that's not gonna
be able to do that so let's see oh I see
okay it's not like a could turn it or
anything so that does that so maybe it's
like a puzzle and I gotta just send
things to nope it's not a puzzle it's
very obvious I I don't even know why I
bothered to try to think that one
through that was just throw them in
there and you're done I forgot I was
been able within where the puzzles are
assumed to be done by two-year-olds just
like the target audiences game with all
its nice words and pretty graphics what
am i doing what am I doing wrong
hey excuse me now oh that's right I got
a crank to yank that thing that I said
that I was gonna do but I didn't do
because I'm stupid oh okay what gun was
that that was not my gun Oh some Colt
those JoJo's gun what the hell where'd
that come from
alright you wanna dance bra lady I don't
know what you are well we're gonna we're
gonna have a fun time I don't know did I
get ya hey lady
whoa wait whoa whoa what's with the fog
oh is that your pheromones your love
potion oh you dodged it oh you saucy
lady oh no are we gonna play hide okay
you're not hiding and seeking very good
or should I say very well this is where
am i incredible amount of sprint oh hey
there you are
hey don't throw that goop at me lady
lady I know I know I know you're excited
but please stop being so aggressive I
need some romancing before we do the
dance yay whoa flailing flailing
flailing Flynn oh no you're on your back
Oh what did you just eat jet rocket to
the wall because I was pretty cool if
you did that all right you're not done
are you
oh no I'll never find you okay where are
you going this time huh
yeah cuz I got a special surprise oh my
goodness you're looking so good
thank you whoa hey God with that uh well
I got a bunch of flashy dues is that
gonna do anything for you I'm gonna
mesmerize your eyes or I'm gonna take
these bullets and go on my merry way
we're yet whoa okay there yeah
where you go so shy one a good thing
these things exploded into bullets Asher
is fortunate for me
three bullets no way I'm done gah I was
just getting into it lady don't go
ladies don't go lady oh yes pass right
through me
oh she's walking Richie give me the cold
shoulder damn it don't know me well oh
oh she's gone well farewell kiss with
this green goop we'll have to do goodbye
lady I hardly knew ye
let me just heal up and I'll be on my
way so sad
who loves bitter bites or whatever that
poem is I don't even remember like I
said before oh it's so hard and
difficult Campbell alright then I'll
just be on my way since apparently
everything else is doing fine oh wait a
minute
well ain't this is good for me it's a
goodie bonanza this is probably what I
should have been getting before the
fight actually started my bad oh I
thought oh you thought I needed all that
oh you thought I wasn't good at the game
oh I can see where you got that from
considering my last few videos so with
that being said and with me being
insulted I'll just move on so oh I get
it
oh no I don't I got it but I got
something else and I was wrong I thought
I had to go back huh thump dude hey
freedom free the key wait what your head
landed over here lady I'm so lonely I
tried to flirt with a giant squid
monster okay bye
yeah I wouldn't want to hear that story
either she was so pretty
let me tell you okay wherever this
elevator is going take me there now
Oh up Braxley going up I went the long
roundabout way to go up why did I even
bother going on that subway train it was
a terrible decision
horrible horrible decision also why
weren't there any medical journals to
try to talk to me about how the hell
that thing got made whatever the hell it
may or may not have been all right
please tell me I'm about to find Joe Joe
because I'm very very lonely as some
people may be able to tell I need some
human contact otherwise I'm gonna start
a family down here it's gonna be a
disgusting squid-like family hello lady
another one oh yeah I never had so many
keys in my life can I get in here
something in there I need nope okay
that's a negatory oh I haven't even been
through it yet oh well great for me I
haven't even done the thing I set out to
do in the beginning kind of dingus and I
I think I remember this from Toy Story
it didn't undo well I can't I just focus
in on that light and zoom myself to it
oh the chapel okay hi all right then
that's that's cool
that's good nitro cup for you
congratulations on becoming a lawn
ornament and more getting me you whoa
that's kind of creepy
what do you mean by that what do you
mean by me
oh we're about to have a sudden
realization here things are not as
hexane well oh I thought it was I
thought it was trying to blame me oh you
will die is that what is gonna be why am
I still going on the precariously first
thing where metal rebar is being smashed
through the windows why suffer Oh suffer
hi Riddick I got your message
yeah this is bad now I run cuz running
before was stupid and not cool I'm not
in control anymore
Oh joyous day frabjous day
Callooh Callay we're back in the
hospital alright where are we now can I
find Joe Joe please I'm very lonely very
lonely Joe Joe Joe Joe
you published my research in your name
again did you think I wouldn't find out
maybe you have no credentials
you'd never appear in a reputable
journal otherwise well no I have
surpassed you in every way you can
imagine
no matter I have what I need
all that's left is the procedure you
only got me and the doctor you having a
close moment answers why we are here we
okay oh hey you wouldn't dare you
couldn't complete it without me
precisely
Oh Oh
so the doctors an equal douche equal
parts Duchenne douche great everybody's
just a backstabbing bastard Oh could I
please out okay well that's a big thing
for you smart I didn't get none of that
where those bullets go that I needed so
much hey you know no no no you're giddy
estas stay stay down whoa okay all right
you want to kiss I that's fine I
understand
don't know what that I just did to you
whoa okay this is getting a little bit
more dicey than I would like y'all
please fall down
why aren't you falling down Hey all
right how about how about a little bit
of this never mind I'm gonna miss cuz
that's what I do in these panic crisis
situations Hey Oh what you gonna do
why'd you fall down already fall down
boom fall down okay got this one see Oh
see his unplug C was not unplugged
before ow my groin why would you do that
to my groin one more
good chunk hey where'd those bullets go
I really like this oh well alright then
it's my baby she's alive I think not
sure not sure about that one but I'm
gonna go with the live because dead
would be even creepier than what I was
doing before so we're gonna stick with
that I really got nothing else to say oh
hi Gedman how you doing that is you nice
music
did you just learn learn yesterday cuz
it's beautiful what are you doing to me
I had a brainwave I had a brainwave
we all volunteered to be plugged into
the machine she's a part of it it's all
an operation to stop Rubik or something
I don't know but yeah yeah yeah yeah hi
[Music]
huh oh good all right then
kind of weird I'm not sure what to
expect about me shooting myself if you
couldn't tell that was me that was
Castellanos Basten loz whatever his name
is I don't know either way something
weirds going on around here
and I am trying to get to the bottom of
it well the top of it so wait music what
are you back here lady lady lady nobody
here at home
yeah kind of weird huh a little bit
lonely when you're talking to yourself
you crazy man
maybe I'm not even really mean missing
short brown hair brown eyes response to
nickname that's good nickname that looks
like Kidman ain't that handy
internal affairs interview transcript
and then investigator Phil I know you
know why you're here
detective Castellanos because you people
do in your job you've been pursuing an
unauthorized investigation using KCPD
resources to do so in addition there are
reports of threats intimidation and
physical violence
Castellanos if you had any proof of
those allegations you'll be taking my
badge and gun right now you've obviously
been careful otherwise we would have but
we're watching you Castellanos you're
not the only ones what's that supposed
to mean
Castellanos keep following me you'll
find out soon enough
you keep drinking like you do we won't
have to Castellanos I've got work to do
here are we finished here for now what
you're on thin ice Castellanos you're on
the edge ya know if I get even one more
and more report you're through
Castellanos I'll be through when it's
over yet Castellanos leaves the
interview room very dramatic I hope you
enjoyed my reading
what okay so Leslie's a bad thing right
that's what's the dealio Leslie is bad
Leslie is very bad or at least someone
getting a hold of Leslie would be very
bad but why would it be very bad
yes explosive bolts my favorite the one
that I love to use more than any other
Leslie if you could stop being
unbelievably psycho just for a little
bit yeah like you got straight on what
I'm doing here and I'll come visit you
in just a moment
it's gonna go and I'm gonna go be
totally sane and inject goop into my
brain why you gotta be so weird I'm
gonna upgrade my shotgun because I said
that I was gonna my shotgun is very good
and I kind of been letting it stand
alone would be so much better so much I
mean the only thing that doesn't really
need an upgrade is the sniper rifle cuz
it's just plain ol powerful so long as
you can get your headshots everything
will be a-okay before you do that I'm
gonna save just because I feel like oh
the name of this chapter is evil within
does that mean that this is the end of
the game oh my god am i close to the end
of the game career lads life oh all
right then
well I was I wasn't I was okay then whoa
Leslee this way okay wouldn't it be just
hilarious if the only sane one here was
Leslie well this is still decrepid hey
you didn't fix my room and fix it out
there
well lazy not fixing okay I'm on my way
come back Leslie I'm all my coming I'm
on my way
don't mind me not gonna run much I guess
how'd you get I knew this had to be some
sort of experimentation thing it's all
part of it it's all part of it I was
looking for my wife I got plugged in the
machine beforehand we're not no no this
is real I don't know maybe I don't know
the only reason Kidman's here is because
she was following us that's what it must
be we must have all but I am pretty sure
we were all in this long before the
hospital we must have been long before
we get to the hospital we must have been
all in this already why are you taking
where are you taking me are you taking
me
hello Lee are you Don don't mind the
song
[Music]
Rubick ain't happy oh yeah it's gonna
help a lot I guess think that means a
bomb went off somewhere
let's look dangerous reminds me a scene
out of Captain America the first one all
right Leslie stop running so far ahead
I've only got eight seconds a sprint
takes me a long time to pick it back up
um yeah I'll be there when I'd be there
I know I know
whatever I'm on my way at the last
minute I'm now yep that's like what the
15th cave in I've been in so Rubik
wasn't too happy with me getting close
to the truth so what is the truth why
are the textures on the upper side of my
face better lower better worse than my
lower one that made sense what's
hey we're here we're here just like
Joseph said yeah so is this am I here
because Rubik is leading the air or am i
here because I need to be here that's
the big question
cuz Rubik might be messing with me
little bits
Rubick might be trying to throw me for
the loop Rubick might be trying to mess
with my lucky terms I don't know why I'm
diggin I'll just carry on it a little
loopy on these long recordings you know
thanks a lot hi Leslie you're here okay
bye what the brick a frak was that why'd
you do it to me Leslie I'm sorry I'm
gonna break this backs their backs yeah
Leslie don't make me do it again don't
make me go over here and explore and
make sure that I got all the special
items that I needed don't you dare
oh oh you did it you did it this time
that was totally worth this endeavor can
I go elsewhere and get more stuff no
okay I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming
I'm a little tired
Oh Oh Oh golly
maybe I shouldn't go all out for that
distance over there alrighty then
well that was awfully convenient
I love the speedy mode of travel there
yeah bursting forward a few steps at a
time really saves some effort so this
isn't wait this isn't the hospital this
is a church no it's Hospital no this is
definitely the hospital I thought it was
kind of like the church but this is
definitely the hospital yeah I knew it
too this is the beginning of the game
but what does it all mean
hey was this jar brain goop here before
oh man this guy died reading this book
it must have been so boring it killed
him oh that shows reading is bad kids
don't do it books are for nerds okay I
[Music]
should probably focus on put South Korea
so I'll do that
I'll do that I'll focus so I'm trying to
explore the environment to make sure
that they don't miss anything because
they know there's gonna be something
whoa hold the freaking phone there I'm
about to do a slow-motion replay of
whatever the hell just sighs I saw yep
that was freaky okay never mind that
we're just gonna act like that didn't
happen Castellanos is totally normal
not at all freaky deaky well this is
where Rubik jumped me Rubick popped into
my good old brain here there's a boxes
over here just up bunch of boxes and the
supply boxes what are we gonna do with
all these boxes and just smash them up
rising steadily
did I miss something wait I feel like no
unless no I feel like I missed something
and I just got to go back I got that
feelin sorry I'll be hang on one second
I just need to make sure that this door
over here doesn't lead anywhere where
does this go anywhere oh I can't open
and nevermind then I'm dumb all right
Thank You atmosphere for kickin in
telling me that I need to go forward
you're of a great grade oh okay ah I
thought I kicked that open already
was this where the guy with the chainsaw
chased me maybe maybe maybe it's all
starting to look familiar but I'm not
sure where I've been and where's just
new area I know that son on that door
said do not enter this area but I'm a
badass I'm a rebel
wait think I'm just gonna wait for some
stupid sign I'm Sebastian Castellanos
wasn't house name right okay not Booker
Booker do it's the other guy
[Music]
that was another sensations has that
broken my serene examine my work of
intensity pleasure rage ecstasy
blending together into a single piercing
noise until the darkness was broken by
sparks noise
the light blends together takes shape
it's a place I know so well oh my god I
know what happened got this on yourself
I know what happened they took him and
they peeled him away layer by layer
until it was just a brain left holy cow
oh my godness Oh hesitate it's our
[ __ ] did was this this seriously
looks like the area where I was running
away from the guy is there anything down
there that I need is there any reason
for me to climb into this pit of blood
oh my god that's so coochie crazy yep
wading around in blood wading around in
good Hey look green goopy I don't know
how I found that in the blood all right
I guess I'm done well smart of me why
did I go why why would I do that because
it's a video game and I'm crazy okay so
he's just the brain he's the brain that
I've been seized the brain and all the
promos that's Rubik why did they do that
to him the doctors a douche oh it's so
cookie crazy this totally is where I was
running away from chainsaw man I knew it
I knew it I knew it I knew it
wait were you going to tell me Leslie
Leslie was the body that he was going to
try to assimilate correct I don't know
he's the only one that was actually
compatible it's going to let Rubik out
into the real world got to have that
where did I go god damn it Leslie doing
that little board forward stops me from
checking everything
no sir do you still dream of escape
newer note from sewer do you still dream
of escape so near at hand what is the
point of dreaming when your body lies
here never moving
I don't know that's kind of creepy and
ottoman this which way am I supposed to
go which way did I go hang on wait a
second here where'd it where where was I
where do I come from where did I go
where did I come from cotton-eye Joe
can't tell where I've been but if I had
to guess that seems like a way out that
seems like a waste somewhere else
reminds me of a game that I played a
long time ago in the sewers who's some
indie horror game I can't remember what
the name of it was but it reminded me a
lot of this not vanish not vanish else
is here this is a bunch of stupid stuff
it's a bunch of stupid oh that's where I
came from okay you bopped me over to
here okay well what was the point of
that Leslie you're just disoriented me
I'm carrying on so I'm assuming that I
do need to go out that way but this is
last way I need to check come on legs
don't feel me now all my legs failed me
oh no all I remember is that I got a lot
of raw sewage in my leg heck maybe that
guy was the chainsaw it was actually
real that was the only injury that
seemed to have been sustained it doesn't
hurt anymore oh god damn it are you
kidding me I'm fine
that was literally all I came for
alrighty then I'll take the sniper
bullets it was a little boy in exploring
this area just some time to collect my
thoughts so that I can try to understand
this strange world I'm in a little bit
better or just wasting time that's what
yeah yeah okay so who left me that sewer
note is that the same guy that was
talking to me in the in the oh the
prison in my mind whatever you call it
maybe they use the goop that
maybe they use the goop that grew those
twins and changed that doggone Rubik
brain and they made it big and weird and
gross
all right things gonna pop out of these
because these things these theme like
things that things might pop out of just
just say this is gonna be an endless
loop okay Leslie is that okay
spiral staircase it seems awfully final
you know they never put a spiral
staircase in it unless it's coming to
the end of the game they never risk such
a huge asset I'll be there in a second
I'll be there in a second how are you
first like I decided to do from the
get-go Oh some detective catalano's
[Music]
the device I should have created my data
my equipment my theories my mind they
replaced my house can't still can't say
I feel sorry for you I'll say I'll say
I'm a rooster okay so now I can carry on
now that I know more about this story
so are we inside Rubik mind are we
inside the machine or is the machine
rubik's mind where's the machine the
thing that allows Rubik mind it will be
alive and connect with other people
is that what it is cuz I don't know I do
not know please take me away to wherever
the hell I'm going now am I going to
fight the brain yeah blow it up with
bullets with mine bullets maybe now
maybe maybe not what do we got here
nothing nothing nothing no nothing Oh
rainy Wow I don't remember that being
there this is some hospital
thank you yes please Hey look what is
that over there oh I thought that was a
savior door nevermind who's in there
thanks for the musical tones
well isn't it well where am I going did
I go this long way just for a bottle of
juice I guess I did Anna Matt fragment
it's all worth it in the end
yay five thousand so let my voice crack
a little more surprised at how much that
is I guess it might have been worth it
that could be another useless upgrade I
pretty much believe that you'd play
through this whole game without doing a
single upgrade because why not also I
run really funny going up the stairs
that's why I say that thank you
d yeah that'll ooh hell I was like whoa
okay top down to you much what are we
doing why are we here
you all right there buddy got a smile I
see well something will be to take that
away soon enough me it's me
is Leslie still Leslie or is this all
cruel ploy why else would he stop to
feel the rain on his skin unless he
didn't have skin to feel rain with that
is Rubik i'm just gonna call it right
now I'm calling it sounds inane right
here sounds inane right something ain't
right
alright let's go find out what's going
on I'm gonna ascend the tower to do
something I don't know what anything
here there's a lot of stuff to explore
but not a lot of stuff to be had about
it what do you got for me detective got
the nose attorney in law
No okay hello creak whoa okay I thought
those a human leg nevermind anything
else no story oh my god it's just a
chair there's no even oh alright then
just save this is just it this is it
this literally it oh my god what do I do
I am NOT ready I thought I'd be ready I
guess I could do that is anything else I
can do seems good enough to me oh let's
go on this seems pretty final I'm just
gonna go ahead and say that right now
this seems really really final and I can
save yes I can that's pretty much the
only thing I could do why did my nurse
go away my nurse I miss her very much
a message prohibited zone blah blah blah
blah blah okay
prohibited zone okay I thought there
might have been like a secret Easter egg
message hidden in the walls oh this
seems very fall my goodness
good I was tired of the day I was
wondering one night was gonna creep up
on me hey watch jeez what I know I'm
right here
what who are you
be that guy from the poster what's that
I'll see okay alrighty then
that was weird well this guy seems very
dead poor guy rest in peace what are you
kidding me you think that's normal do
you really really think that's normal
huh all right whatever fine be that as
it may I suddenly am NOT controlling it
is that his eye oh no wait a minute this
is a memory Oh
or no okay hi good to see you again nice
brain
yay suck on that douche
yeah it's fired bring it back a lot of
bad memories huh a lot of bad memories
yeah yeah take that repressed childhood
although I guess being on fire would
disturb anyone so that was his eye that
was the eye thing that I need to do okay
okay I'm gonna pop those suckers
oh there's eyes everywhere oh my
goodness oh my goodness oh my good god
look ouch
that seems horrifying I'm gonna shoot
your eyeballs now I'll be don't mind
hope you do not mind boom boom okay did
that do anything for you how do you feel
now buddy huh friend huh what's going on
oh good company I was waiting for you I
was eagerly awaiting am I gonna have any
ammo around here good good good good
good yes please
thank you very much oh this guy's come
from this side to each it's like a
goddamn party yeah pull do do hey guy
god I miss god I missed again
there we go I didn't miss that time whoa
no no no don't what are you doing what
are you doing what do you do
how's that guy still alive he was pinned
to the wall who's doing that whoa
where'd you come from
whoa now what I want to know whoa whoa
okay all right whoa all right
whoa hey are you still alive no he's not
he's not very much not alive there we go
that's awesome all right there we go you
done done done done woes or someone oh
you're still alive
there we go whoa you're you need some
extra doing there we go let me burn you
just in case whoever else wants to burn
with them please feel free there
anything up here that I might need there
like there would be yes goodies okay
what now
hi Raven how you doing funny that you
should mention that your face is your
vulnerable spot oh never mind then
I was this good I thought I was gonna do
something thought I was gonna do
something clever there oh damn it he's
not vulnerable ha ha that was a less
significant yeehaw
it was a yeehaw nonetheless I eat harder
I've got I forgot
hey hey whoa whoa there buddy
oh yes sonny jim yeahö can you stop with
the arms please yes Sabu with the arms
oh god I'm tired
oh this ain't good you gonna do huh what
are you gonna do forget it all right
you gotta spaz out again god I'm all out
of stuff yeah up there you where we you
want us there we go okay yeah got ya got
ya I'm gonna burn you burn you burn yeah
why didn't you burn what are you gonna
be special
can you burn - please thank you don't
know I have two matches left
oh yeah supposed to be shooting the eyes
baby can you just I'm supposed to do
here is it there's the thing I'm
supposed to pick up there
I don't know I'm running out of ammo
probably just wasted about trying to
shoot the eyeballs it was probably a
very stupid adventure okay who's coming
yeah that's not gonna really okay fine
be that as it may I wasted all the way
mrow who cares
I'll get more maybe no oh hey welcome to
the party
I am literally out of ammo besides for
this gun damn it
I'd done frickin goofed all right let's
make this interesting
mom that didn't kill you
what is this baloney malarkey
Myrna there's a lot of you now oh it's
an adventure someone's thrown something
not okay buddy you chill out okay I miss
my pun was bad and I should feel that
shoot please shoot please thank you
oh that ain't good well I'd heard a lot
dogs please don't climb on my head I
mean I'm in a bit of a pickle no not the
goop who did that who did that who did
that who Zuzu's it was a jokester
who's the prank man hey go get blinded
while I come by again collect this [ __ ]
the two bullets okay almost got me
without whoa don't don't no no no I said
well shoot it whoa what no it's on my
body but it was on my body and you what
if we stop looking at that I'm in a bit
of a predicament burn please thank you
is there any other items that would be
of value to me cuz I need him
whoa did I get a twofer now come on
yeah yeah got friggin RPG man over there
please let me okay well a good thing I
did that healing that was totally useful
can I not get stuck in a loop of suck oh
really oh really
you just alrighty then this is fun this
is fair America crackalacka yes please
blow up your friends please Oh God
oh you were chainsaw guy okay that burns
his face went on the other side of the
room man I need to figure out what to do
with you well we is our boot in there I
would like why you have the high ground
and I got nothing I got a whole lot
enough whoo goddamn shoot the damn thing
oh god no no God [ __ ] a thing why
wasn't my harpoon gun shooting that's
like the last guy I probably got goes to
the old damn thing again
my art poon was not shooting you kidding
me right I gotta go through the whole
damn thing again I do don't I you're
really gonna be that big of a
son-of-a-bitch about this aren't you you
son of a [ __ ] you piece of [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] fine you know what
I'm not gonna waste my ammo on the
freakin eyeballs wait I'm already out of
ammo you're starting it over you're
taking all my ammo no no no no no there
we go whoa whoa can I have that back
please
what the [ __ ] no way Selleck that was a
direct hit screw you oh god oh god oh
god oh god okay that's just not cool
Oh what the [ __ ]
all right okay you want to dance buddy
let's dance that was right on but in the
shin how do you like that
oh you don't ask too bad it's all I got
shin shots come on [ __ ] up thank you
well us I got I got a whole lot of
nothing except for this yeah Magnum baby
that's more like it
what's out should be taught should have
been you're done son you're done you're
dead you're done
hey you know I thought with the eyes
there it was I was supposed to shoot the
eyes like house eyes not supposed to
know
maybe now so God that is brain is this a
whole lot of brain right there yeah
Brody's hello hey all right
wow that's just rude no you don't you
yeah yeah bullets oh no you died oh did
it in that whoa
fall over don't get to throw it yeah
yeah how do you like that huh all right
I think that got him
give me that poon give me some more I
would love some more stuff right now
because this is actually testing my
skill a bit if I hadn't run out of ammo
like a goober I would have been just fan
just a fan you say finally give me
something in the way of a sniper ammo
boost in your time in your time mister
man in your time detective Castellanos
whenever you feel like it
don't let me hinder your progress that
seems decrepid Punk
hey somebody here well that's a long way
down too bad here we go all my shins I
am all dead okay you gonna give me some
actual supplies to not give me something
that looks like I'm supposed to shoot at
it because it definitely looked like I
was supposed to shoot at the eyeballs
let's go say that
anything else I don't know why those
spinny trappy things are down here but
I'm assuming I'm gonna have to come back
and suffer through them her chunk I'm
guessing this is the traps that Rubik
was talking about because rubix said
that he trapped up his place of good bit
so that nobody could come get to him but
he looks like his plan failed and he
only use a living brain I see the box
heads over there sound of the assumption
that they're gonna come alive and more
sniper rifle bullets yes please goodness
gravy it's been too long since I had my
sniper rifle I love my sniper rifle
anything down here any shotgun shells
you know as far as the survival horror
aspect of it does go they do tend to be
very very very sparing with ammo that if
you don't go shooting the wrong target
for about 10 mins but that's not my
fault not my fault at all okay here we
go
what are we got going over here oh there
was a oh I see those all clever ruse oh
this two of you now divided only need
two of these to take out one of y'all
what that did it before oh come on now
so we got back a nails man over here
you'll thud oh you gonna you're gonna
fall over you're gonna fall over I can't
shoot you in the face so you better just
fall over
woah okay this is are they activated
activated Kobi fall over
oh hey enough room over here for both of
us maybe can you just fall over I did
not do this ride
running into a wall okay yeah good good
thing I oh yes stung on me don't mind me
went back a nails had probably hurts but
I'm too badass to tell whoa wait can you
fall over
oh this guy this guy what does he think
is what does it think is oh you don't
know no eyes what was I thinking
stick I shot his head okay off off off
to the races
I am running out of ammo
oh no charge no charge Oh charging so
what am I supposed to do here
what I supposed to do exactly what am I
supposed to do some ammo over there whoa
whoa whoa mr. bull man what a load of
bull God I'm [ __ ] me god damn it no no
no no no no no not what I want not what
I wanted give me the goddamn healing
juice okay well all right then let's
have a nice kiss shall we well I went
horribly God these guys are tougher than
they used to be and then sue them how am
I supposed to have enough ammo for this
yeah you dingus you didn't give me
enough ammo game gear all right uh-oh
Peep Bo Peep Bo Peep Bo Peep Bo Peep Bo
Peep puppy starts me way back again ow
my crotch right on that thing maybe I
gotta use the environment to my
advantage
zombies do some like traps around here
that I could get them in on but as far
as me I think I'm on my own all right
let's try this once more shall we Oh No
it was all a mirage Oh No stand up your
dishes I'm gonna spear I'm gonna focus
on one try to remember which one right
in the balls should give him some pause
oh why why No oh god that couldn't have
gone more terribly oh boy get up ya
dingus use the thing you're not the one
that I was shooting before are you
she had unless the other ones coming
down this way then I might be screw it
okay what happens if I trigger this
again so that does what exactly okay
that locks that guy out so he has to go
well I didn't help me at all
whoa damn it with the headshots I don't
want the headshots Wow what the [ __ ] oh
my god game you just don't want me to
win do you you don't want me to wins
keep that up
yeesh okay that's the one I was shooting
before I think I think anyway wookie so
they throw down traps so I guess in a
really dodged with the headshots in a
really desperate situation it would call
for the ability to take their traps and
use them [ __ ]
this shotgun really sucks at a distant
donut
okay let me just try this come on just
do it do it do it do it do it do it do
it do it do it do it do it got one yeah
one all that effort for the one I'm
gonna run out of stuff this doesn't do
anything to you I know it doesn't all
right that took a little longer than I
thought it would
I got it eventually though good for me
give me your goop if I ever get a chance
to use it I'm gonna kick your teeth in
all right on my way where am I go now is
it final time bat or am I going to have
to fight all the bosses that I fought
before is it going to be Mega Man style
is what I'm asking
whoa whoa whoa Rubick I revoir goodness
all right I wasn't trying to I don't
know what I'm doing here oh it's your
eye so I guess that one that I need to
shoot do I need you at that one in
particular
God your your brain walls are really
weird whoa okay all right I get it I get
it I get it I get it I get it I get it I
get it the eyes quite literal blah blah
blah don't get caught in them or else I
die probably alright okay speed run
speed run baby speed run baby woo okay
no no no come on I know what I need to
do
okay come on come on come on it's gonna
take some time
yo okay
yo ho yo ho whoa I don't know if it's
gonna be instant death but I'm just
gonna assume oh yeah hey whoa whoa whoa
little speedy ensure your speedy eyeball
sir pass through yeah there is okay that
go through there I can make it I can
make it I can make it whoo whoa okay
that ain't good
well that's all a lot of bad do I have a
Grenada I do not okay so uh about that
okay
that's problem I think I know what I
could do I just don't know if it'd be a
good idea where here we go anyway yep
the Delta TR daddy I did it I did it
good I did it's real good okay what am I
looking at now
[Music]
you are talking [ __ ] now [ __ ] is this
go anywhere we go
good job your only sucks all right I
really I feel like I'm really close to
the game end of the game but then again
I'm back to where I was before
when are we gonna finish this this is
gonna be the epic finale it might just
be you never know it's so kooky crazy
what's happening man I don't know
can I just get some supplies that's what
I really want just some damn supplies
okay so there's not even enough great
station anymore it's just visit this is
all I got fine you want to be like that
I'm guessing this really is the end well
then good for me so you're gonna give me
any supplies some supplies please
supplies surprise surprise no I'm just
gonna be scraping by
whatevs whatevs you know if I had never
found this agony bolt cross crossbow I
never would have been able to beat the
game because this would have been
absolutely unbelievably horrible the
whole way through
I wouldn't been able to craft anything I
wouldn't have any last-minute weapons
I'd be dumb okay we're going up the city
17 style
oh that's Castellanos for you very
clever witty and clever well we're going
pretty high so what does this mean for
me this is a metaphor for Rubik getting
really high on me whoa alrighty then
that's some amalgamation of what is
probably a brain though that looks that
looks like I can't zoom in why not why
why why come on now
well that was dr. Jimenez looks like
Leslie
that's Jojo that's kid man
so we are all part of this and that is
the paramedic where is me there is me
there's me am there me am is me that is
mean it can be
it totally candy I don't trust you
Leslie too bad I got no bullets in this
gun
sebastien listen to me stop your
interests are the same as ours look I
get it you're not just some rookie
detective and this is not just some
ordinary kid you killed Joseph and you
shot me so right at this moment that's
enough reason for me not to trust you
you're a good man
that's why I
doesn't matter anymore if you know who
this kid is
did you know anything you know why he
can't be allowed to live [ __ ]
it's Rubik he's the one
okay then this is the climactic finale I
guess just wanted this episode to be a
little extra long to make up for the
shore last episode whoa well grody gross
no don't do it
wait so that thing that we were trying
to stop this whole time just happened
I'm guessing oh boy wheel and Leslie
right to it
oh boy ask that
okay very good whoa whoa I'm a little
drunk
BAM
Oh God
oh wow okay then where am I going now
oh that brain got big Oh does this hurt
Rubick Rubick do you feel this oh
there's a bunch of brains now this is
nuts
Oh
oh hey oh my goodness well do you have
gonads underneath your neck are those a
weak point should I shoot at that high
Rubik high dome buddy
you look good you look great
okay never mind others I gives up every
bone in my body is now broken
except I don't have a body it's like the
matrix okay okay well what chance did I
have you just start me on
okay well then that was anticlimactic
all right oh now we're going dots to the
right right okay oh yeah that almost got
me a mile away gods to the live
oh no a truck that's to the ride last
whatever
okay oh that's a strange bus panel panel
a model
you've got breasts animal please okay no
time to run perilous run no clock
eh I got it's like he really wants to
kill me or something
I thought we were friends Rukh but we're
buddies
he's your big
okay then all I get good thing this
truck is here floating in mid-air oh
it's got a machine gun on it
how perfect for me my ideal weapon
you're out in the Midlands this makes
sense
Oh targeting reticle laughs well good
thing I'm a good shot right in your ugly
face
you look down here weird brain head
that's your big old gonad we're going
our gonad oh I'll get it
how about I shoot up your big ugly brain
then
ish there's so weird and trippy but at
the same time it's awesome
it's like it reminds me of a house of
the Dead
you know the sequences on the bosses
Airwolf go bad and I'm own enough oh no
no man machine gun moment I had such fun
with that that was pretty awesome you
got okay
well it's bound to happen eventually I
just got to remember it's not actually
real it's all in my head
oh hey Oh perfect
why not using it if I borrow this Chum
friend buddy that's gonna take that why
don't you mind okay here we go
apparently this is happening now oh yeah
I seem to have an unlimited supply to
don't know why god damn he's moving
around it's gonna be hard to hit him in
his face Oh
I say anything for that giant sack ow my
spine no I'm supposed aim for that how
am I supposed to oh he's down Oh Cassie
you want any other I've got the plan
team you're gonna swing to the right Oh
gotcha
kneel down [ __ ]
show me your cranium that's a nice brain
there would be a shame if someone
exploded it okay I only got a few shots
left so I gotta make them count come on
good thing my last two Rockets are going
to be critical rockets come here you
that's a nice brain
maybe oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no no no no no you didn't tell me this
is gonna be like this here gonna make me
do it over aren't you
that is some [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
you have to admit val is [ __ ] it's
the rule of threes you're supposed to
get three shots on him that's like it's
like the thing by whatever I'll play
your game you weirdo
total miss I can deal with that
cool
face oh right in the face well what the
[ __ ] you're not supposed to do that
damn it damn it damn all this hell
okay sauce is supposed to aim for the
brain the whole time I coulda shot it
any old time god damn you damn you damn
you damn you damn you damn you
bastard
oh yeah that didn't kill me how again
with everything being broken and somehow
that guy is still moving
how my alive I Riddick how is this
happening
I don't even know can I do it hey rich
Oh alrighty then
wow that was something oh hey hey I was
going ok gross you hey I'm all done here
ok hell yeah this is the real world the
mine the real world yet probably not I'm
gonna go ahead and say no this is gonna
be a super long video by the way I'm
already over an hour in ten minutes
that's rubik's brain i created this
world that's where i beg to differ
No oh I thought he was leaving man ok
I'm coming for you baby I'm gonna punch
your brain I'm going yeah I'm gonna
punch it really hard Hey look I got a
toy okay
yeah time to stomp time to stump can't
believe it man that's so weird to think
about the entirety of a human is just in
that gelatinous blob grody
I don't even know if there was another
choice that I could do yes
[Music]
yes I okay shush all right then uh leave
that one and those two no one can
excuse me you want to run that by me
again
okay hello
so rubik's brain is still that that guy
doesn't look fun that guys having a bad
time oh my god Ruben's brain is gone
ruvik all ruben Victoriano i get it
ruvik okay Jojo alive okay
Leslie withers Leslie where's Leslie
so we did all go into the hospital and
that's what 100k so this place is still
a horror show
why what happened wait a minute what
[Music]
detective are you all right is there
anyone else just give me some real fresh
air
Leslie Leslie that Rubik yeah the police
would just let a guy in a straitjacket
just walk right on out
oh boy that ain't good that ain't good I
knew it wasn't over oh boy
what is he now just gonna be confused as
to whether it's a real world or not what
no no no no no there you don't know
I said no
[Music]
ah boop-boop
god damn it off come on I got so many
questions oh I get so many questions
about it I have so many theories going
into me and you're not gonna answer a
single one of them I was under the
assumption that were there long before
that's what I thought everyone was
leading up to why was with all the
missing people things ah
there's probably so many questions that
need to be answered because I didn't get
all the collectables I didn't get all
the map fragments because I didn't get
all the story signs but still the way I
thought that story was going I thought
it was going in a totally different
direction oh man oh man oh well I guess
that's it I want to wait until the end
of the credits to see if there's
something afterwards because I feel I
feel like there's a big piece of the
puzzle missing is he still in the
machine and what's up with good men ah
doesn't make any sense it's I'm totally
another confused I'm trying to piece
this together in my mind
the game is stuff okay game itself
totally fun it's fun game it had some
pretty easy puzzles but they had some
pretty interesting set pieces even
though it started to repeat after a
while in the second half of the game it
got a little bit of repetitive and loss
of scariness but it was still fun game
but it's just worried about the story
right now like come on you can't do that
to me you can't drop a bomb on me like
that oh I don't know wonder if there's
anything else that needs to be done okay
I'm gonna wait until the end of the
credits then I'm gonna say something
else okay wait patiently okay
machine gun machine gun why do I care
about the machine gun good thing that
guy's hands are crossed over Rubik
private parts good I guess Roget that
would have been nice before fifty
thousand skill points new game model
viewer yay grades total number of deaths
oh this would be good only 34 that's
probably not that bad maybe considering
it was about to rack up hundreds of them
oh come on
I'll save your game fine you better have
something for me after this you better
have something for me after this well
nope
that's the end of that the only thing
that it's changed it I think this turned
orange I think it was blue before oh man
[Music]
I thought there was gonna be some
answers to my questions oh I think
they're just setting up room for a
sequel you know that's what they would
be doing oh well hey when did I have a
trenchcoat I wish I had my badass trench
coat with me that would have been nice
oh well and there was no answer about
his family there was old Fang leading up
to his family about how his wife was
trying to solve a mystery and yet it
didn't get answered like nothing about
that got answered and then Jojo just
disappears I have so many questions to
be answered but it doesn't doesn't help
me don't know me I wanna know maybe the
answers lie in Rubik crotch wait a
minute if I turn it just this way he's
still disgusting and gross all righty
then oh I don't know the haunted oh good
oh good brass knuckles I would have
loved to about the brass knuckles wow
those look awesome
yeah either way okay I guess that's it
so I'm gonna need your help with this
guys I need you to go down the
description or the comments section talk
about this game I'm gonna be reading
every comment if there's something that
I missed please let me know I'm not
gonna go back and make a video about it
but I want to know for my sake like I
want to know if there's other videos
that people who play the answer some
questions cuz I got so many questions I
don't know if the ending is just not
satisfying or if there's just something
that I missed
so let me know in the comments below
either way this has been a long game
much like aliens it's quite an endeavor
and it's always cool to see the end of
it and it's got it in a way it kind of
makes me feel like
it's over now what but it was so a lot
of fun and I had a lot of fun on the
journey I hope you guys into some I like
doing these long Let's Plays this is I
don't get off and get a chance to find a
game that I really want to do it with so
I'm glad you guys join me thank you
everyone who was here from the beginning
thank you guys who joined in later thank
you everybody for watching you can check
out other series that I've done every
game that I've talked about in this
series will be in the description below
all the other long series that I've done
you can check them out if you want more
story so thank you again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
something's gonna happen
[Music]
entrails of the fallen on their face
[Music]